on sunday relative calm returned to sri
lanka
protesters remained at the president's
official residence making use of
facilities normally reserved for the
country's elites
a real carnival atmosphere here at the
president's official residence the great
facade you see behind me you notice the
architecture it goes back many many
decades and this was the site of that
massive sea of people who overran this
property seeing the exit of president
gotabe rajapaksa on friday and the sheer
number of people trying to get in to see
the president's house is posing a real
problem those who are part of the
protest campaign who are still trying to
control some of the crowds are urging
people to be careful there is structural
damage obviously a very old property and
just cannot handle the sheer numbers
climbing up the staircase there has been
structural issues so that's posing a
very real problem and a danger and this
obviously the swimming pool at the
president's house uh the water looking
very much worse for the wear but those
iconic pictures of people diving into
this right after the protesters
essentially overran this residence sri
lanka's 22 million people have for
months been suffering the worst economic
crisis the nation has seen since
independence in 1948.
the summer heat worsening electricity
blackouts fewer food and medical
shortages and years of political
corruption
the greatest thing the people and the
youth of this country has ever done is
to chase this man away he was expelled
chased away he did not resign
as the protests swelled on saturday
president gotabe rajapaksa fled his
overrun residence his whereabouts are
unknown
he is no longer the president of sri
lanka he has been expelled by the
citizens of sri lanka therefore this is
a victorious moment
official resignations from leaders for a
nation in rebellion now little more than
formalities this is going to be an
extremely critical time to ensure
there's political stability as well as
economic stability at a time where
there's also a law and order situation
erupting so
if violence is not contained there is
concern that this is going to deepen the
crisis
overseas remittances and tourism are the
main sources of revenue here
after bomb attacks on churches and
hotels in 2019 and then the kovit 19
pandemic both dried up
the recent political turmoil has been a
long time coming and is likely to be an
equally long time to recover from but
for millions of sri lankans it's not
clear yet whether the shortages will end
and prices come down
miner fernandez al-jazeera colombo